I thought it was mr. cool up till now
and look at me now okay
see what's going on everybody's four
first three feet I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot one it's a show a
taught question even how to wink Sam
joins I'm Mac DeMarco here's a tour
coming soon so keep an eye out and that
is forthcoming album this old dog is set
to release on May 5th Mac welcome to the
show thank you for having me how are you
with hot food I like to think that I
like it but perhaps we're about to find
out how are your stomach issues I know
you used to have some stomach issues if
they improved over the years no no
actually I had a pretty spicy burrito
last night so have a bit of the ring
effect going on right now oh this is
just going to compound the effects
looking okay thank you have a good show
[Music]
first one is sriracha sriracha is not a
big deal to spread here up no no no okay
so I read in an Esquire profile that you
should submit yourself to medical
experiments as a way to pick up some
extra cash which sounds like a great way
to make some money if you're in a fine
but I imagine that there are some
pitfalls to that yeah it wasn't really
extra cash it was just the only cash I
would and wasn't very much cash and it
turns out you know you do all these
strange things run on treadmills they
have the magnets they worship magnets
and in the skull we return you know
cognitive you read and we all just all
of the money five bucks an hour
sometimes waste of time extra funny
story with that will do they don't tell
you what the drug is going to be right
interwebs where you going and it was
going to be like a new viagra or some
equivalent so would have been me all
these other guys in like hospital gowns
with boners no no okay
not interested yes kind of weird all
kind of crap yeah glad I don't have to
get anyone okay
yeah oh that's for mmm okay I know that
you've toured North America to busted
down Ford Escort hatchback sedan and
I've heard you say that you prefer the
van to the tour bus I'm not taking a
tour bus why middle wheel why to waste
money waste money and also you got to
get on there like two or three in the
morning you got no control over your own
life some weird driver guy that sleeps
all day and then always awake at night
like some vampire I want to travel with
this vampire I don't want to you know
I'm still weird is too weird but if
you're taking an old broken-down car you
know you have some issues too if you
think about the times that you were
stranded on the side of the road are
there any Dory's that kind of stand out
you're just broken down actually we had
on my mom's car
dodge Dodge Neil yeah me on Fort Dodge I
don't
broke down in a town called st. Marie
Northern Ontario middle winter kind of
took a - in the candies I guess we're
going to be done for two days or like
kind of walking around like you were the
good side of stuff you know look this
guy think his name was Alfie or
something found us on the street a
guardian angel took us to his house
macaroni and cheese he refused trying to
give us clothing amazing never saw the
guy again but appear out there god bless
you from the outside looking in you
maintain a pretty powerful diet of cheap
beer cigarettes and pizza but despite
living in Montreal in a Bushwick you
seem to have no patience for these
hipster foodie trends so what I want to
do is bounce some of the biggest
obsessions going on right now I just
want to get your snap take on it okay
that's how good okay all right you
impressed by our production over here I
like it yeah I always hang some people
god bless all right double IPAs
I hate IPAs what I'm having a beer it's
so that I can feel the effects of
drinking alcohol you know and you don't
want to have like a full meal no I don't
want to you know I don't know times one
and they're more expensive than a normal
beer
just keep it Lockard get it out of here
juicing are you a juice guy no no no no
my girlfriend she loves it I don't I
like smoothies you know juicy take away
all the skins the bits the chunks you
need that that's good for you yeah
avocado toast are you an avocado toast
guy I do yeah I like toast I like
avocados it's kind of like Australian
breakfast vibe right there but um the
price that this goes for nowadays is
ludicrous
especially of what the bread in the
toaster $8 for piece of bread oh my god
ridiculous
got a wolf on it and a wolf flavors okay
[Music]
so some celebrities are known for their
Jim selfies and others for their witty
tweets but I think that your greatest
social media contribution is the hashtag
I'll see hashtags like Jar Jar Binks or
Fifi short but fat dick on photos then
point you're neither Jar Jar Binks nor
fat dick yeah yeah yeah the internet
changed a little bit I feel like we
didn't have the internet merit program
in Montreal so I missed a little bit and
when I came back what is this I didn't
understand gave it a crack and now
people are loving it I said I'm not you
know to speak to charge all right I'm a
huge fan of his hopefully we'll be
seeing in some of the upcoming Star Wars
you one of the few guys that wants to
bring Jar Jar Binks back on we're out
there it's someone who craft lyrics for
a living is there a poetry and hashtags
or is it all just kind of [ __ ] I
think that all social media is pretty
much total baloney that's why I treat it
like that the terrifying space
especially for young people these days
[Music]
mmm sweet lovely moon so the next
brother show is called explain that gram
and you've seen the show before so you
know how it works we do a deep dive on
our guest Instagram you pull interesting
pictures that we think need more context
so I'll show you the picture and then
you tell me the broader story that sound
good oh good right laptop back out so
chicken milk he talked to me about the
Eric Andre show you did the Eric Andre
show we did Eric lovely guy crazy guy
perhaps but lovely
I was actually crazy some perhaps you
seemed a bit where these guys are
beating me up with these bamboo sticks
he told me though they're not going to
be using like real you know swords or
whatever it can be like you know props
with the prop swords are still made out
of rubber I walked off with all these
like crazy welts across mine it kind of
hurt oh it's crazy yeah it was pretty
insane and when they tied me up you know
I was like it was legit guard war yeah
it's integrated Canadian I think here
he's up there for sure to do the show in
for him yeah I know this and I've got
this present yeah ok this was crazy you
know say say the injuries he did in the
90s with like blue earth Sonic Youth or
Nirvana or whatever they had no idea but
amigo I mean obviously I'm like I love
you mark more so but wasn't he had some
crazy stuff yeah did it surprise you
even if you go in with those
expectations yeah he did surprise me a
lot of the things I was just kind of as
soon as you say something to be like who
told you that you know that was what was
the cogs were going off of was it me
Ryan more I have one more for you this
last ones of video oh yeah
dad do you know the proper term for them
lighting a fart on fire blue angel why I
say your farts on fire the funniest
thing you can do a fart is funny enough
just on its own but it's like you get to
a it's like it's double trouble you know
all right so the next one you're
probably wondering why you have a purple
wing and that's because this next one
blueberry mm-hmm blueberry ghost pepper
rock and all you have kind of a
laid-back disposition but your live
shows aren't that way they're pretty
high energy from getting butt naked on
stage to crowd surfing you put yourself
in some pretty precarious situations you
ever get in trouble with two venues have
you ever had a situation where you had
an awkward face-to-face to say a
promoter or a club owner
tap the funnel you know you get up on
the balcony and you're like I'm gonna
jump back into the crowd and securities
but no no no hey the elata buddy you
know it's like that's kind of that's
what makes it fun for me and we had
bread man in here and he was telling us
a story about what he was vibing out
with the crowd one time he was on acid
so he didn't really notice it but a fan
was cattle prodding him while he was in
the crowd with them you ever had a fan
like commit a borderline felony on you
actually will see that this see this
scratch right here cuz you can see there
yeah that one I thought it was going to
heal up and go away but I think it might
just remain now but this is from
somebody's fingernails at Glastonbury
last year but I get I get beat up out
there quite a bit but no no count
project that's a little bit yeah kind of
made me I should rethink the creds every
day after hearing that was kind of crazy
so this is where the game gets a little
bit crazier than it has been so far now
we're up Dombey Apocalypse Ono okay down
the chute
oh yeah this one's moving okay now we're
getting somewhere
open it up a little bit you know so many
regard to is sort of a dirtbag life
coach and I mean that as a compliment of
the highest honor so what we've done is
we pulled some common life dilemmas that
everybody goes through and we just want
to kind of get the Mack DeMarco guide to
self-improvement does that sound good
yes sir that's hang over here hot wings
is it though I'm feeling you know yarns
work in the field and getting the
hitting rare sport but you feel like you
deserve a raise how do you approach your
boss on them perhaps with polite and
free excuse me Mary
please have erasers for madam or
whatever give any advice for quitting
smoking
I'm sure you've tried a couple times is
there anything that helps those where
for me yet that I'm a mom or this book
some book where you supposed to smoke
and then you read it and then at the end
you're just kind of happy that [ __ ]
you're good I don't know if you should
try to well maybe I will maybe I will
how you feeling I'm good yeah tingly
lift like it you own it together good
yeah
surprising them suppose myself now oh
right off the bat
oh yeah go beyond insane before
oh damn it
yeah oh damn it
yeah okay oh yeah okay now I see Alice
oh yeah what is this one the bomb what
kind of pepper oh yeah Donna hmm thought
it was mr. cool up till now and look at
me now okay okay don't want to talk
about clothes breath second I've heard
you describe your look is what bum chic
no no something like that oh how many
consecutive days of wearing pants is too
many consecutive days of wearing the
same pants yes I think you can get away
with first for a little while oh and why
should this you safety pants I smell
like pee wash them at the bottom line Oh
what about picking out a hat because you
think you like your hats like a worn in
catcher's mitt how do you pick out a
good hat what's the look for they
usually come to me would you
yeah my girlfriend gets me a lot of them
times kids will gift them to me
sometimes they're stolen the longer they
stay the better oh boy
the other favorite right now I've got
this one with a union honest if the
concept is ru Niang a little bit of
balance
and my girlfriend gave it to me so it's
very sweet yeah oh wow I wonder what
these next year gonna be like you just
kick certain acts
oh the mock-up more I'll just crush on
this show Internet man you cannot apply
okay oh boy oh yeah you're good at this
sir well you know what it just I've gone
through it so many times and now there's
like some responsibility on me I feel
like so I think that helps I like this I
just cry in front of someone very often
so here we are vulnerable opened up over
wings and hot sauce Nakagawa throughout
yeah are you sure all right so what I
want to do is you know oftentimes on the
show we'll have guys with iconic beards
talk about other iconic beards with you
I want to talk about the gap too because
the gap tooth Club is a very exclusive
club so what I want to show you are some
gap tooth icon and I want to get gap two
icons ranked according to Mac DeMarco
this one sneaky it's hit me out yet
sneaky it's a little [ __ ] sneaky guy
yeah
lip Oh Madonna Madonna did she always
have a cat though I think so like what
but you wouldn't put that in some people
do know some people don't want to be in
the club other people wanted so bad but
if she's oh gee god bless her like Titus
Mike Tyson I could you know it's crazy
we watch that you see the like she chose
her toward that that one man show up one
man show I don't really know that much
about Mike Tyson I was really impressed
that he was able to do that I don't
think I could do that he's had been hit
in the head for like you know 20 years
it's crazy that's me magda mark oh yeah
I'll tell you the funny story about this
guy so he was a kid I went I thought oh
yeah I'm gonna need braces to get this
shot did you just like no no no so I
could go to a point where I was like
what's up this
come on here and otherwise namely all
covered but you learn unless yourself
there's only one place to go to to make
a death sauce wet with liquid rage fuel
lies whose Blair Blair where dude from
New Jersey boogers all over my hand is a
dude from New Jersey that likes to make
it spicier whoa this is the sick one
this product contains the hottest known
ingredients on planet Earth please use
extreme caution it is tradition around
here put a little extra dab on the last
wing okay you don't have to if you don't
want to overuse one but you're pretty
composed Mac little tears it was you
there you go okay we got some kind of
fiber a little hustle Wild Wings chefs
eyelash in minutes for extra flavor and
then whoa [ __ ]
well I yeah you know what you gotta
breathe with yourself you made your bed
now okay
you're a wild man
this is maybe the most generous dab
we've had on the show Julio might have
had you beat he doubts the whole wing
really yeah spicy
yeah real spice and real showman Julio
yeah yeah
[Music]
Griese way to go okay so you know
despite everything that you've
accomplished in your musical career the
trappings of Fame don't appear to excite
you much so I have to ask
while we're dying on Blairs Megadeth
sauce with liquid rage what does success
mean to Mac DeMarco
when are you happy okay yeah now it's
running it's coming in now coming real
game but to start drooling that
happiness I think that no human really
understands how to achieve happiness if
you set goals for yourself maybe you
reach them maybe you don't they take
baby steps and you don't know what's
around the corner perhaps being happy on
the journey
razzes and at the destination it's more
easily achieved well my nose hurts but
Mac you made it through a little bit of
drool there at the end that's alright
I'll still pound it this camera that
camera that camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life
going on tour soon help you out there
the nose feels fresh - punched the nose
fun it feels like I've just been long
come on - shows if you feel like
listening to my new record do it if you
don't that's fine
perhaps you'd like it perhaps that you
don't it's also fine we'll be out there
2017 your freedom rocket for your
pleasure if you desire it if not don't
worry about it okay
season mom how do you think he'd do I'm
very dizzy what's going on hot ones fans
if you liked the video maybe meet us
halfway throw us a subscribe if you
didn't like the video don't subscribe I
don't want you I don't want you in the
tent but if you like the video subscribe
thank you very much
I appreciate you I love you more than a
friend